this is too far look who's back
hi no it's a great intro uh so yeah he's
got up he's caught up on the episodes I
knows what's happened everything good
night in big Jewish triangle head at the
foot of my best that's the only scene
you saw he didn't see our episode just
said that so he can make it look like
he's oh no I know actually I will say
this catching up on it yeah it's really
a tight race between Perot and peridot
is my favorite characters funny they
don't get along yeah
no peridot just amazing um yeah that's
and then yes we have another one end and
Doug's already talked about but all the
updates with the plot with a question
the cluster and Bill in the the drill
which now they're going to be building
but and Stephen being useful to peridot
yes that's uh it's really I got nothing
cuz you talked about it already okay
let's talk about this episode this is
one that focuses now on one connection
we haven't seen yet between peridot and
amethyst where uh peridots discovering
uh humor and goes too far with it and
hers amethyst feelings and cheese as you
can probably imagine she's understanding
emotions more which you know on top of
being the enemy uh you know we've
established that gems and feelings you
know are kind of strange and you know
socially awkward and stuff at least
compared to humans so it can make sense
that this would happen and once again
she finds a way to sort of say she's
sorry and she wants to form a friendship
and stuff but through the peridot way
through like recording and saying it but
you can't and you say it herself which
basically said yes it turns out they all
suck but I guess I suck too so you know
one of the what I was saying before uh
talking about this is that you know
these episodes with peridot they seem
cliche like we see as a million times
but the cliches I like and it's kind of
the same thing here with like the way
you have this you know and she's
supposed to be like this super villain
everything but a harnessed will like
restrain her and stop her and she can't
like you know and she's like a little
kid you know just trying to get it off
and
whining and complaining uh and I love
those I was like Mary's like her
comments made me feel uncomfortable
they just tether her to a pose well and
I like how again she's so good at
isolating everybody and then like the
one she seems to have like the most
seemingly the most connection with she
hurts the most a you know without even
realizing it and let's let's also add
fuchsia phobic yes she's got some future
phobia got real fuchsia phobia um two
together I did you know I file it's
God's law what I love about you know the
prejudice in general is that when you
try to rationalize it like intelligently
like you can't you know and it's just it
just comes down to makes me you know to
my you know you can't rationalize it um
so yeah the the one I mean it's a good
episode it's kind of uh I don't want say
by the numbers I picked up the space my
travel sign is still on that bar and
yeah I was ice call back um and I kind
it was a bit uncomfortable but in a good
way I felt like you know when she's sort
of like just constantly sort of reaping
and amethyst I'm like her sense of humor
is like Trump's it's not so much funny
cuz it's funny it's just wow an asshole
actually said that
yeah it just comes off like woo so her
sense of humor definitely needs work but
but you see that she actually is not any
more out of necessity she legitimately
feels bad for hurting somebody now um a
Yoshi is for me more and more of a
connection uh unlike Trump yes though
they have the same kind of hair like you
today that's sure like um but uh uh yeah
it's a I mean it's a good episode the
one thing that I'm a little curious
about is uh I wouldn't be except for
this one joke where she's on top of
amethyst it's just like oh that was an
accident it's like oh it's okay you the
drill was no problem oh yes that too and
it's like I wonder if they're setting up
like some kind of crush or relationship
or something like your mama I mean it
well we already have plenty bow chicka
wow on those um but yeah it actually
it's mostly chicky chicky
um well this could be more Chiki Chiki
awawa i don't know or maybe it's just
like maybe it was just a joke and maybe
it's just a friendship you and I said oh
yeah
I think because this um because this
race you know doesn't seem to have male
gems and O's kind of like anything is
you know calves off-limits there's even
more possibility of like characters
falling in love with her well now we're
finding out apparently it's just like
well amethyst is the only real gem even
well he carried a well because the cos
pearls a pearl and garnet suffusion and
well that's still two gems again I think
she's going by prejudice you know
matters fuschia phobic but but even that
there's something wrong with Amazon well
this I'm realizing more and more and
that's I didn't put that together in the
last one all of them have their own kind
of outcast settings don't because
amethyst is too small she's not the
right size pearl is not technically a
gem she's supposed to be a servant and
when we've seen sardines of judges yeah
well then when I'm thinking about it
when we've seen some of the other gems
they see more Heather large yeah you can
kinda see why there was the one they
went up against that was a good size
like intimidating sized rose is big the
water one out lapis was earlier yeah
she's not that big
yeah she's she might be the the odd one
out maybe it's different sizes but I
guess it depends - if there's different
kind of like races with them because
like amethyst is supposed to be a
soldier so maybe they were created bread
whatever to be larger but yeah we have
seen some pretty good sized gems and I
do when I look at those through you kind
of be like I mean garnets the biggest
but she's it even than that Stan's two
small ones coming together so I'm kind
of wondering but then I get it what the
is peridot uh malachite but I don't
know what that means this oh we haven't
see another malachite so I don't know
did they did you look that up or did
they say it I think they said it I
forgot when they said there's so many
episodes of no no what am I talking
about apparent that is actually what the
name of the Janet gem is a peridot oh is
it that's what I was not aware of yeah
I totally forgot that was just some
goofy now okay cool no Malka that's
right if someone invents the new
mutation or whatever I am me I have
never heard of that uh I would every I'm
gonna have to look that one up no I most
like pretty much all the other ones I
knew I'd I've not yeah it's a green
stone
oh you learn some new every day fine
Steven universe well no I always thought
it was a play on paradox you know that's
what I thought
oh yeah I know it's something with my
thoughts yeah I thought initially she
wasn't even a gem of some sort she was
some robot thing but of course they took
the robot you know our the the live when
she called them in that episode I cut up
into the limb enhancers yeah yeah um so
I love by the way in that episode they
just dumped it just like whoops Wow
douchebags but my favorite is still a
scent sponge the the different names for
everything is granted oh what's right at
your bud I mean gravity that's a
perfectly gravity connectors yes I mean
those are great terms those are so funny
and then to end on you know that your
but I mean that's that's a perfectly
told you I kill it this whole time
though this was one big scam and para
dad's really gonna like blow up the
planet by creating this drill and stuff
just you know that seems unlikely or I
know if she's going I gotta have those
knees and out yeah where it's like that
was her original plan but no she can't
she's far too strong a friendship um oh
no ultimate betrayal um so curse your
inevitable betrayal so uh yeah good
episode anything else you gotta know I I
just found it enjoyable yeah anything
we're I'm count with you peridots Pico I
heard on and pearl are my favorites
personally but um yeah no she's I'm a
pearl girl somebody sent me on HSN I'm
gonna have to make a teacher at it ya
know somebody actually to actually there
are a couple uh people they put together
like a pro girl um sure design so good
job uh and I got good god I got so many
gifts because I said the gif of or the
image of peridot spinning in the toilet
like somebody make a gif of a me I mean
like so many people send me gifts in
there so thank you great I got plenty uh
I was very funny um so yeah that's about
it we will see on the next one
later